بسم
الله بسم الله
عشانو
[Silence]
الله
يخل
شكل ما شاء الله ما شاء الله
[Silence]
خيك به الحكي
‏da
[Silence]
‏so
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
الله اكبر الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر اشهد ان لا اله الا الله
اشهد ان
لا اله
الا
الله اشهد ان
محمدا رسول الله
اشهد
ان
محمدا رسول الله
[Silence]
حي على
الصلاه حي على الصلاه
[Silence]
حي على الفلاه
حي على
[Silence]
الفلاح
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
لا اله الا الله
[Silence]
ان الحمد
لله نحمده ونستعينه
ونستغفره ونعوذ بالله من شرور
انفسنا ومن سيئات اعمالنا من يهده الله
فلا مضل له ومن يضلل فلا هادي له واشهد ان
لا اله الا الله وحده لا شريك له وان
محمدا عبده ورسوله صلى الله عليه واله
وسلم يا ايها الذين امنوا اتقوا الله حق
تقاته ولا تموتن الا وانتم
مسلمون يا ايها الناس اتقوا ربكم الذي
خلقكم من نفس واحده وخلق منها زوجها وبث
منهما رجالا كثيرا
ونساء واتقوا الله الذي ت سون به والارحام
ان الله كان عليكم
رقيبا يا ايها الذين امنوا اتقوا الله
وقولوا قولا سديدا يصلح لكم اعمالكم ويغفر
لكم ذنوبكم ومن يطع الله ورسوله فقد فاز
فوزا
عظيما اما بعد فان اصدق الحديث كتاب الله
وخير الهدي هدي محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم
وشر الامور محدثاتها وكل محدثه بدعه وكل
بدعه ضلاله وكل ضلاله في
[Silence]
النار عراق
‏not all
[Silence]
indiv
tr br that
‏tres
confusion like
ask face
truu is that this world is a place of
test not re
‏never us
that would
not in mind made
isig
meing
life des
‏this our ed ed sy home
sch and even in our
frid generally not h ser about
deion we foc more
onw
behi than
‏val and the fr whinging for the
here all of this is because of we
fai this is how people think
and
they unfor sch
‏life pr so can succeed
in can
الله increas
weal
from الله
eas
are there are phases that doesn't affect
us much
الله سبحانه
وتالى so we
mo make the
re الله
[Silence]
‏unfor that
ment yes
was and
ى الله عليه
ولص to
me hear
and in times e and difficulty
[Silence]
اللهث
مدينه جنه
اسعد ابن
راره صلى الله عليه وسلم
الله
all by
sword take
[Silence]
الله صلى الله عليه وسم
‏by
those evenes
‏show
they
tru this place
of only the day
of
ران الله كل نفس داقه الموت وانما توفون
اجوركم يوم
القيامه الله ان الله اشترى ان الله اشترى
من المؤمنين انفسهم واموالهم بان لهم
الجنه اللهن
‏this is the
guarantee every beli
جن for that when we are
asked are we for
death the answer should
yes all
asit subit الله
صل الله عليه وسلم
[Silence]
الله رضيت بالله رب وبسلام نا
الله
لتبلون في اموالكم
وانفسكم
الله ولنبلونكم بشيء من الخوف والجوع ونقص
من الاموال والانفس والثمرات
وبشر الصابرين
سبحانه وتعالى ولنبلونكم حتى نعلم
المجاهدين منكم والصابرين ونبل اخباركم
[Silence]
احس الناس يتركوا ان يقولوا
امنا وهم لا يفتنون
[Silence]
الله الله ذلك الفوز
الكبير جنه and called the great
success you
know about the
sit اسلام us anything other was agreed
upon to make you
‏our happ in this life the answer is yes
it
does the beli community
pred and
security in this
life
what
and the
‏the
re the
here even so these individuals also
today liv in a ty of worldly happiness
they tested in sy they
are but they are happiness
الله سبحانه
وتعالى الله سبحانه
وتعالى الله ومن عمل صالحا من ذكر او انثى
وهو مؤمن من فلنحيينه حياه
طيبه
ولنجزينهم اجرهم باحسن ما كانوا
يعملون لهم البشرى في الحياه الدنيا وفي
الاخره الله س سبحانه وتعالى لهم البشرى
في الحياه الدنيا وفي
الاخره لا تبديل لكلمات الله ذلك هو الفوز
العظيم
[Silence]
‏they and underst them and they
stood they knew that these
[Silence]
‏and
hope الله سبحان
وتالى الله سبحانه
وتالى and certainly in
his being willing to sacrifice for sake
having goods of him
and trans
[Silence]
ازه الله سبحانه وتعالى سد قالوا لن نؤثرك
على ما جاءنا من البينات والذي
فطرنا فاقض ما انت قاض انما تقضي هذه
الحياه
الدنيا انا امنا بربنا ليغفر لنا خطايانا
وما وما اكرهتنا عليه من السحر والله خير
وابقى تو
[Silence]
‏am
ex pres and
contentment in the lives of our brs and
sisters who are great trials in the mus
world cri
ands
may look look
[Silence]
الله سبحانه
وتعالى وعد الله لا يخلف ولا يخلف الله
وعده ولكن اكثر الناس لا
يعلمون يعلمون ظاهرا من الحياه الدنيا وهم
عن الاخره وهم
غافلون
life he
[Silence]
يقول الكافر يا ليتني قدمت
لحياتي
الله
ايان اقول قولي هذا واستغفر الله لي ولكم
فاستغفروه انه هو الغفور الرحيم
[Silence]
الحمد لله رب
العالمين والصلاه والسلام على اشرف
الانبياء والمرسلين سيدنا محمد عليه وعلى
اصحابه افضل الصلاه واتم التسليم اما بعد
‏to
far
think
الله
الله حديث حديث قدسي ابو هراه محمد صلى
عليه وسلم الله سبحانه وتعالى
‏takes takes friend
as my servant does not draw near me near
to
me with anything more beled to
me
iig
upon and my
‏sees his hand
act
ands im being friend of
اللهي of الله im being so cl
الله sour
of hearing
[Silence]
الله وما يلقاها الا الذين صبر وما يلقاها
الا ذو حظ عظيم
‏are
for this is the re for those who sinc
for the sake of
الله
seing ‏it is a that is open to all us no
matter where we are in life allah invit
us draw close to him closer to him and
he promes to resp with blessings and
protection may allah gu us to the pa of
righteousness accept our good and make
us among those are close to him may us
اللهم امين واعلموا ان الله سبحانه وتعالى
امركم بامر فبدا به بنفسه فقال جل في فقال
جل في علاه ان الله وملائكته يصلون على
النبي يا ايها الذين امنوا صلوا عليه
وسلموا تسليما اللهم صل على عبدك ورسولك
محمد البشير النذير والسراج المنير وارضى
اللهم عن عن الاربعه الخلفاء الراشدين
المهديين ابي بكر وعمر وعثمان وعلي وعن
بقيه الصحابه وعن التابعين وتابع التابعين
ومن تبعهم باحسان الى يوم الدين وعنا معهم
بعفوك وكرمك واحسانك يا ارحم الراحمين
اللهم اعز الاسلام والمسلمين واذل الشرك
والمشركين ودمر اعداءك اعداء الدين اللهم
ادفع عنا الغلاء والرياء والربا والزنا
والزلازل والمحن وسوء الفتن ما ظهر منها
وما بطن عنا وعن سائر بلاد المسلمين عامه
يا رب
العالمين اللهم ثبتنا على قولك الثابت في
الحياه الدنيا وفي الاخره ربنا لا تزغ
قلوبنا بعد اذ هديتنا وهب لنا من لدنك
رحمه وهيئ لنا وهب لنا من لدنك رحمه انك
انت الوهاب واصلح اللهم احوالنا في الامور
كلها وبلغنا بما يرضيك اما ام لنا واختم
اللهم بالصالحات اعمالنا
وبسعاده وبسعاده
اجالنا وتوفنا يا رب وانت راض عنا اللهم
اجعل جمعنا هذا جمعا مباركا مرحوما
وتفرقنا
تفرقا وتفرقنا تفرقا معصوما ربنا لا تدع
لنا ذنبا الا غفرته ولا هما الا فرجته ولا
مريضا الا الا
شفيته اللهم اصبغ علينا نعمتك وعلى جميع
المسلمين واملا اللهم ق قلوبنا بالايمان
ولجميع من سبقنا بالايمان واتنا من لدنك
رحمه وهيئ لنا امرنا واتنا من واتنا ربنا
في الدنيا حسنه وفي الاخره حسنه وقنا عذاب
النار ان الله يامركم بالعدل والاحسان
وايتاء ذ القربى وينهى عن الفحشاء والمنكر
بغي يعظكم لعلكم تذكرون واذكروا الله
العظيم الجليل يذكركم واشكروه على نعمه
يزدكم ولذكر الله اكبر والله يعلم ما
تصنعون الله اكبر الله اكبر اشهد ان
لا اله الا
الله اشهد ان
محمدا رسول الله
حي على
الصلاه حي على
الفلاح قد قامت الصلاه قد قامت
الصلاه الله اكبر
الله اكبر
لا اله الا الله
استووا استقيموا تقاربوا تراصوا يرحمكم
الله استووا ولا
تختلفوا الله اكبر
[Silence]
الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب
عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين سبح اسم ربك
الاعلى الذي خلق
فسوى والذي قد در
فهدى
والذي اخرج
المرعى
فجعله
غثاء
احوى سنقرئك فلا
تنسى الا ما
شاء الله
انه يعلم الجهر وما
يخفى ونيسرك
لليسرى فذكر ان نفعت
الذكرى
سيذكر من يخشى
ويتجنبها
الاشقى الذي يصلى النار
الكبرى ثم لا يموت فيها ولا
يحيا قد افلح من تزكى وذكر اسم ربه
فصلى بل تؤثرون الحياه
الدنيا بل
تؤثرون الحياه الدنيا
والاخره خير
وابقى ان هذا لفي الصحف
الاولى صحف ابراهيم
وموسى الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله اكبر
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امينين اذا جا
نصر الله
والفتح ورايت الناس
يدخلون في دين الله
افواجا فسبح بحمد ربك
واستغفره
انه كان
توابا الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
[Silence]
بس
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Silence]
السلام
علكم comm
[Silence]
‏some
‏man ‏make
maning imped us because
sch sch make there kids are and we have
to cle the by the
just
make are maning sch
[Silence]
الله ا
‏pap
[Silence]
‏s
‏ja ا